toy animation has released dragon ball
super superhero recently and in
celebration of that film i decided to
ask animators that have or are currently
working for toy animation around the
world to help me transform the film from
modern cgi to classic 2d this is what
they created and as an added surprise
one of them has animated a short
sequence from the film stay tuned for
that the first image to get the 2d
treatment however is this shot of gohan
being chopped by one of the gammas and
the first animator to draw it is
barcarot barcarot is a professional
austrian animator currently working on a
number of high-profile projects i'm not
allowed to reveal just yet but bacarat
is a phenomenally talented artist having
worked on shows like the new digimon
series in 2020. this is but one of many
images background has decided to
contribute for this video and boy does
it turn out amazing unlike the prior
installments of this series we wanted
these animators individual quirks and
styles to shine through unchanged and so
the final result is something very
dragonball with a lot of baccarat's own
style visible also he incorporates
wonderful shading and smears to help
convey the intensity and speed of the
attack on gohan the hair has a bounce
the lighting is dramatic and compared to
the original image the difference is
night and day amazing stuff baccarat
next image up for the redraw is
this sweet shot of gohan being kicked by
one of the gammas and the next animator
up to draw will be
glass glass is a uk born animator that
has delivered some brilliant work to
modern one piece fans of the series will
no doubt recognize his work he's worked
with some of the very best toy animation
has to offer including the likes of
tuyongsu and magumi ishitani the latter
of which helped to deliver some of the
best looking dragon ball super and one
piece episodes to date and today he's
decided to take this image of gohan
being kicked by gamma number one and
within this video you will see artists
that tried to stay as close as possible
to the original images layouts and
composition and others that
fundamentally change it too this time
around glass has decided to change the
composition of the image to something a
little more playful and dynamic instead
opting to change the layout to gohan's
face being kicked towards the screen the
exaggerated posing is filled with energy
and personality with the wonderful
expressions offering up the perfect
cherry on top of this wonderful cake
incredible work glass it looks awesome
next image up this touching shot of
gohan embracing his daughter pen and the
animator tackling this will be
andy chu
andy is a korean argentinian animator
and storyboard artist and her career has
taken her all over the world from
working with disney in the west all the
way to japan working with animation
studios like toei animation studio piero
and mappa on shows like digimon boruto
and dance dance dancer i personally
think that one of the best parts of
dragon ball super superhero is that for
a cgi film it looks incredible the
animation and art direction takes full
advantage of the new medium and moreover
many of the more awkward angles that cgi
might look a bit scuffed in have largely
been redrawn over by 2d artists already
this is such an image and due to that
really the only thing that needed to be
changed to bring it closer in line with
the series like broly are the shading
and lighting philosophy as well as the
line weight of the piece respecting
kubota's designs andy has delivered
another wonderful and faithful 2d
representation of what this film could
have looked like had it taken that
approach wonderful work circling back to
gohan's fight with the gammas again and
we have this shot of super saiyan gohan
looking all cool and stuff and back to
redraw this is barcarot
i think my favorite aspect of barcaros
drawings is how dragon ball z error they
feel in design however due to this
backrot is required to redraw the
foundations of the drawing itself using
the original image only as a suggestion
rather than a strict skeleton he has to
follow the structure of in fact the more
i look at it the more it reminds me of
the work of takahashi's modern
interpretation of the buu saga's
yamamuro i love the dramatic lighting
incorporated in the drawing as well as
the glow in the eyes to add extra
intensity with mix adding the final
touches to this piece by adding an
additional light source the comparison
is once again stark and wonderful to
look at but we've seen baccarat draw
gohan now let's see his work with
someone like vegeta one thing i will say
about this artist baccarat is that much
like other professional animators he
works very very fast compared to me
specifically he's like lightning and
much like the other images he's drawn
over the course of this video the style
he captures is a nice blend of modern
and classic approaches to the series and
just for fun he drew some nice wind
effects this time around and comparing
the original with this one the
difference is once again easy to see
[Music]
hey it's me marku you think your current
earbuds are powerful well think again
raycon's everyday earbuds just popped
out of the time chamber and they look
feel and sound better than ever raycons
come in many powerful forms like super
raycon blue but they also have focus on
the form of your ear thanks to their
optimized gel tips you can be shaking
around mid transformation and they will
not budge they've got you covered for
hours too thanks to 8 hours of play time
and 32 hours of battery life that's like
8 hours of canon and 32 of filler
episodes amazing they're super
customizable too for example you can
swap between three sound profiles to
really tailor the sound to your
preference you can also pick noise
isolation or awareness mode to decide
whether you want to be totally immersed
or keep track of what's going on around
you it's as simple as holding the left
or right earbud respectively for three
seconds to cycle through these modes
they really are pristine and priced
perfectly you get all of this fantastic
audio quality at half the price of other
premium audio brands what's that how
many five star reviews do raycon
everyday earbuds have over 50 000.
so what are you waiting for click the
link in the description or go to buy
recon dot com forward slash not mark to
get 15 off your recon purchase
[Music]
next image switching things up for a
moment let's tackle this shot of goku
and vegeta and never to be left out of
these videos completely trev is off to
draw next according to friends of mine
that actually have seen the film itself
they've told me that while the cgi looks
great 98 of the time with all the
appropriate redraws over most of the
sections that needed it there was one
section on beerus's planet that seemed
to be more rough than the others with
the result being this shot of goku and
vegeta duking it out i suppose the fear
with cgi in the first place was that it
might look a little too much like a
video game and at least in this shot
that was the case for us the base
structure itself is relatively okay just
the clothes and faces needed tuning up
all things considered once everything
was said and done with mix's filter
applied everything looked great nice
work everyone and nice work trev
this glass is wearing gohan is up next
and the artist converting it into 2d
will be angie again i'm going to try to
go through these faster now but once
again respecting the original design
because there's really nothing else
wrong with it and he focuses most of her
efforts on the lighting of the image the
clothing and other aspects of the
drawing interestingly something she did
share with me was the stark differences
that exist in terms of pipeline with
regards the different productions she's
been involved with whether they be in
the west or in the east in japan
speaking of japan specifically required
a deeper knowledge of industry notation
and pipeline in order to work
effectively there and this is something
that baccarat and glass have expressed
too with regards to this final genga or
animation design it looks really nice
and once again mix sends this bad boy
through the filter process and yet
another great result emerges great work
everyone once again
next up on the redraw is this dramatic
close-up of gohan and drawing it will be
bakarat and once again with barcara you
have a very detailed reimagining of the
foundational drawn i think it's
important to reiterate at this point
that the film itself looks visually
impressive and that the purpose of this
video is if you like demonstrating an
alternative reality of what this film
might have looked like had it been
produced using traditional methods
baccarat changes the lighting shadows
intensifies the expression and overall
brings the image more in line with the
drawing philosophy of a more nostalgic
time resulting in this stunning and
dramatic shot of gohan in the reign
against one of the games mix once again
composites the piece in stunning fashion
producing a brilliant contrast with the
original now i mentioned a small
animation that was produced for this
movie in this video but before we dive
into that i need to put forth a quick
spoiler warning this final section deals
with visuals that were not seen in the
trailers and if you have and continue to
want to avoid spoilers for the next two
months or however long it takes for this
to release in your area i will say thank
you so much for watching and we'll hope
that you come back once you have seen
the film yourself with that said that
has been your spoiler warning now on to
the final section
gohan blanco
i'm gonna be real with you guys barkarot
totally surprised me with this one i
didn't ask him to do it and when i saw
the finished product i was totally blown
away there were some
less than good images circulating
following the film's release but
honestly those are few and far between
with the rest of the film along with
this design looking very well but i
won't lie i haven't seen the film itself
and i won't see it until it releases in
my area but the idea of the gohan blanco
meme being canon now has to be one of
the funniest things that has ever
happened to the dragon ball community
most of the people that have seen this
film have told me that it's really good
and personally i can't wait to see it
the wait will be agonizing but
baccarat's short animation of this power
up gohan will help soften the blow and
help tide me over until that time comes
so ladies gentlemen and that technicolor
rainbow in between
i present to you all bacharach's
animated reveal of gohan's new form from
the new dragon ball super superhero film
[Music]
with japan's animation industry growing
larger and larger each year the barrier
to entry has become much smaller with
the majority of studios now relying on
foreign freelance animators
contributions to ensure shows get made
social media has become a necessity for
production managers and it's played not
only a huge role in elevating the
quality of countless anime but also
facilitated this video being made in the
first place it's easier than ever to
reach out to the very people who bring
these wonderful shows to life and as a
result i hope to do more videos like
this one with more animators in the
future for different shows maybe one for
one piece is an order all the twitter
handles for all the artists that
participated in this video will be in
the description down below but until
next time i'm toynotmark i'll see you
all next weekend thank you all so much
for watching
[Music]
estos elfin